so that is the second night of Hanukkah  all over the world Jewish people are  lighting candles on the menorah you know  this is a tradition that goes back  thousands thousands of years tonight  we're going to honor that tradition but  we're gonna do it in our own way that's  right ladies and gentlemen it's our  annual lighting of the vape pen menorah  [Applause]  this is our shows music producer Roey  Hershkovitz really good to see you  mokona  Rowi is holding the vape pen menorah  just as the Bible describes it the Old  Testament yeah now I understand you're  an observant Jew Roey  and an Orthodox vapor is that correct  that's right first we puff the center of  a patek this is known as the shamash  then we blaze the first to vape ends on  the right it's a reminder that our  people once enslaved in Egypt had no way  to get high on the go okay let's light  it up bro we give it to us  [Music]  [Applause]  roni Hershkovitz everybody  it's watermelon  you